there's an interesting tweet that i saw
from jack posobik i saw it from lucret
casca i
saw it from mike cernovich the ten
stages of genocide have you seen this
this graphic middle have you seen it all
right
so jackpot said assess and it's a
graphic that has
ten steps it says the ten stages of
genocide let me read them
number one classification people are
divided into us and them number two
symbolization people are forced to
identify themselves
number three discrimination people begin
to face systematic discrimination
four dehumanization people equate with
animals vermin or diseases
five organization the government creates
specific groups to enforce the policies
six polarization the government
broadcasts propaganda to turn the
populace against the group
seven preparation official action to
remove and relocate people
eight is persecution the beginning of
murders theft of property
trial massacres nine is extermination
wholesale elimination of the group
it is not extermination and on uh uh
it is extermination and not murder
because people are not considered human
and ten is denial the government denies
it has committed any crime
so mike cernovich shared this many
people are sharing it
and they're asking where you think we
are mike cernovich's post said
6.5 just before seven that we are
just about to see official action to
remove and relocate people
i saw many people responding to the
memes saying they think we're at between
six or seven
i'm not entirely sure i'm convinced i
think people might be
really hyping things up like i i
understand there's
like the a lopsided justice system right
now i understand there's problems
but to say we're just about to see
official action to remove a group of
people
i think that's going a little bit too
far from a lot of these personalities i
mean what do you guys think
uh three somewhere between three and six
we didn't form an
uh an organization to take care of
capital police well that was already
formed they're expanding it
into they're becoming a new intelligence
agency and they're going nationwide
right
that's why i said between because it's
not officially a new organization to do
that as well bro
come on the current organization that's
semantics like they didn't build the
republican extermination fund or
anything do you know what the secret
service is tasked with doing
i have no idea tracking counterfeit us
dollars
did you know that no what did you think
they did guarded the presidency that's
right
because that was that was dude the
department of energy the department of
energy is like the biggest weapons
program
that's where i learned that fact about
the secret service yeah yeah they did it
was counterfeiting
and so so of course
i say that's that's that's a semantic
argument the the argument put forth by
mike
which was the capital police are
becoming a local police a federal police
agency just for the for this for the dc
but now they're going to operate in
california florida look man
you you see these things and i talked
about this in chicago they'll knock the
whole building down except for just the
facade
and claim it's the same building but
everybody knows it's not the same
building
the law is so long as one wall stands it
legally is
so the floors are different the size is
different and it's like a weird-looking
building with this tiny like two-story
front brick frame
and there's a steel building behind it
or something ridiculous so anyway
but but i i don't completely disagree
with you ian you know it's broad it's a
broad stretch to say between three and
six
so the first thing i'll point out is
classification obviously we're all
divided between us and them in a lot of
different ways
the left the right the far right
whatever
who's being forced to identify
themselves is anybody forced to do
anything
i'm not that worried i mean this is
america i think we'll figure it out
they've got the pronouns in the twitter
bio but it's not
for some organizations might fire you if
you don't identify yourself well that's
so that i think that's more of the
question here is like it's not your
actual physical well-being more so as
it's like
your ability to operate in polite
society right as
you know somebody who's like you know if
you lose paypal if you lose any access
to
banks and stuff like that i mean and
that's i mean you heard about what's
going on right
uh there was an announcement from paypal
working with the adl to
to weed out extremist transactions and
then facebook youtube and twitter
announced
that they're going to be targeting uh
what are they they say attacker
manifestos in the f
in the far right including the proud
boys content so
proud boys content is now like to be
purged so they're not just talking about
censorship now they're talking about
financial restrictions
and censorship and they're playing this
game of the far right
so all that needs to happen is a sustain
a long enough campaign where enough
media outlets call you far right and
then they can say oh but look it's it's
here he's far right everyone knows it
someone uh i think it was a democratic
politician
tweeted out that their people were
vermin did you guys see that last week
brother they say maggots
yeah maggots and vermin that's the
dehumanization and then the
extermination
it's not murder if they're rats you know
that's what they're maggots but don't
you think
so like i mean i've had both experiences
which is i've had reporters
reach out to me about kenosha for
example and get
totally like talk to them for hours and
have them totally manipulate what i said
you know for their own agenda but then
i've also had you know situations where
like
huffington post and um a new york
article that just came
article that just came out by paige
williams i talked to her at length
and she didn't put that qualifier right
wing daily caller in there
and i talked to her afterwards and she
said yeah because you know i talk to you
and you know you well they're they're
real journalists yeah so they're i mean
my point is is that
it's not like this monolith of just bad
people
in the corporate media i think if you
really make an effort to actually
extend your hand and and try to tell
your truth to those people rather than
just shutting yourself down and saying
no no no you have this agenda and i'm
not going to talk to you
sure you might fall on your face a
couple times and the intercept might put
a hit piece out on you
um yeah this is funny
at least you're trying and i think it
some good comes to that the splc hit me
up
and asked for a statement and so i wrote
like a really long statement
and i was like i genuinely think that
jack dorsey's
stated intention is to have basically
everyone be on these platforms even
people we all kind of disagree shouldn't
we all kind of agree shouldn't be like
there's there's
there are free speech free speech
absolutists but you know there's like
certain things you shouldn't be posting
on social media like images of you know
i'll just i'll leave it at that
and i was like jack dorsey told me that
his goal is immutable
social media that he wants to make
blockchain social medias nothing can
ever be taken down and i'm like
bro that's that's way over the top like
i'm not asking for that
i'm just like let people have political
opinions you don't ban him for saying
learn the code
he's like not everything no i don't
believe him or
he doesn't have the power that he that
people think he has on twitter but so
this guy asks me and i basically you
know gave him a full honest opinion and
he calls me a far right reactionary
i'm like bro if you actually and so what
he did was
there's a clever thing that i think he
did to avoid looking like he's lying
he put my statement as an external link
instead of including it in the piece
because then when you go to it you're
like oh this guy's kind of moderate you
know what i mean like he's not really
far left or anything but
i think you tapped on a really important
point right there though and that goes
back to what we were saying about
you know are we at the point where you
know people are being identified as
groups and you know removed like
physically no but
um and i like coach uh some like 20
somethings you know zoomers
in hockey and one thing i noticed is the
degree to which
you can say whatever you want to them in
person you can throw whatever
words about you want and they won't
really be phased but if somebody says
something about them digitally
it's like it consumes them you know even
if it's just in a snapchat even if it's
an
instagram comments or whatever because
that lives forever
and so like if you google whoever's name
and this news outlet decides to say this
that's immutable
and until you know something else
becomes the top result that's you
yeah that's a big problem with the
because what i've
been looking to say culture uh politics
is downstream of culture
big popular i think it was breitbart
then i realized that well
uh culture is downstream of technology
so these technological algorithms that
are supporting
you know rage trash bait like they say
ian cross owns a psychopath and then
that gets retweeted so then that in
fortifies the algorithm and then all of
a sudden psychopath and e and crossland
start showing up that's why this digital
statement is so much more powerful than
a verbal statement because it's feeding
the technological
problem there a good example is uh
some smear some gizmodo article this is
really funny the left has like one video
clip of me they love to regurgitate
because like the only real thing i guess
they have
and it's from like a year and a half ago
and so gizmodo wrote it up
like a few months ago and in this
article
where they take this clip you know out
of context they claim tim poole's
mostly right-wing audience and then i'm
like what
what does that mean like did you pull
them do you know who the audience is
and then what happened was a couple
other outlets regurgitated the article
and said the same thing
exactly and then someone put it on my
wikipedia tim poole's audience is mostly
right-wing
well like i guess you know i don't i
don't know if it's still there or not
but in the talk second section you can
see them saying like
something about just because someone
says it an article doesn't mean it's
true
and they're like well then a couple like
three artic three articles have all
claimed it
so we don't we we're not the ones to
investigate if they say it's true then
we include it
and i'm like yo none of these people
have actually asked my audience who they
are what they believe
and the trump supporters like the the
the diehard troopers really don't like
me
over like my reaction to joe biden
winning the election it's like
you know we did a poll and found i think
the biggest group was libertarian
the the the the plurality was
libertarian and then
like um trump supporters uh moderates
and then liberals and there are even
some progressives about kanye west
voters
oh that's like 70 like just everybody no
no but the point is
like what does it mean to be a right
wing are libertarians
necessarily right-wing not necessarily
what happened to the left libertarians
of which made up most of the young
people in like the early 2010s
who are now the anti-sjw types certainly
shifting i mean i think we're in the
midst of a shift so
obviously it's kind of up in the air
right now and it's a question of where
the where the chips will fall
but what does left and right even mean
nothing man nothing it it so so
here's the problem you go to somebody
and you and you know we had steve bannon
here
steve bannon said he was far right and i
was like steve you just attacked the
rich
and he was like well i'm a populist and
i'm like how is that that's why i've
always been opposed to that kind of
you know characterization i mean we have
in america because of the two-party
system we have a very binary way of
like viewing our reality and it's like
you know i growing up i don't think it
was that much of an issue like
it was never like oh you you know are
you a republican or a democrat
and now it's like where do you fall i
think
jimmy what do you think of donald trump
well if if you if you like him do you
like him how much do you like him
he's a funny guy make america great
again
do you vow january 6th a vow
say it right now disavow i i i disavow
that's my point though is everything you
know the weirdest thing about online
arguments is
it's like some leftists will come up and
they'll be like well will you
you're complaining about black lives
matter this about january 6 and i'll go
i just about january because it's really
bad and they're like well
and it's really funny right now because
a lot of conservatives are saying my
body my choice
over you know vaccine stuff and the left
is like the pro-lifers have no idea what
you're talking about and i'm like i've
always been pro-choice and i think my
body my choice pertains to all of it
yeah they don't argue with me about it
because they're like what do we say
about that guy
oh he's consistent in his positioning
i'm like dude
it's because they don't understand what
libertarian is
right i'm not gonna pretend to be like
big l libertarian in any way
i'm just kind of like i don't know and
you kind of should leave people alone i
guess
but you're right i mean it's a question
of like cultural conservatism
versus like i would argue that you know
trumpian conservatism
has less of that cultural aspect of
conservatism i don't think you know
like do we all can we honestly say like
what 20 years ago was trump like
anti-abortion
nope he was a democrat not at all yeah
while he was already running a reform
party
exactly doing cocaine off of hookers
here's
the dude's not conservative he's
populist and so he got a lot of new
people into the republican party
but i want to go back to that splc
things i mentioned this before i
mentioned this the other day
when they refer to me as a reactionary
and then show
my full statement where i'm like i said
you know i said bigots have no place in
polite society like bigots
homophobes transphobes racist have no
place in polite society
he includes that and says that's
reactionary it's like okay what you're
really saying is that you're an
insurrectionist
the southern poverty law center these
organizations and these activists
are insurrectionists who want a complete
upheaval and overthrow of the us
government
because reactionary are the people who
oppose the revolution so
you can have leftist values you can
believe in the progressive social
justice cause
but if you tell them they're wrong for
wanting to burn everything to the ground
they'll call you a reactionary
i literally come out like several times
a month talking with people about
healthcare and i'm like i think we need
universal healthcare
like a basic level maybe i've leaned
away from it a little bit because of the
the race-based vaccine rollouts and my
concern is that if we have
government-based healthcare
and then the the racists take over
they'll make everything race-based and
then
withhold healthcare from people based on
that's scary but that's not left-wing
i can say tax the rich not left-wing
what is it
do you support the upheaval and
overthrow of american culture
or don't you because if you if you like
apple pie and baseball or whatever
you're a reactionary you can believe in
all the good social justice stuff
you can make a documentary about
blockbusting and redlining and racism
doesn't matter will you support the
revolution yes or no
but don't you think to a certain extent
the quote-unquote
cultural revolution that you're
referring to is mainstream now like
don't you
think that the critique is now the
mainstream insofar as like the majority
of people
think that about apple pie and baseball
that like you know
america is corrupt and america is doomed
to be racist and terrible forever
i look at the polling and i think it's
fair to say that the ultra woke make up
a tiny percentage relatively but it's
growing i think
in our media i think it's a different
story in the media it's like about 80
percent the algorithm is it's coffee so
i'm not talking about like average
everyday americans because traveling
around the country
right that's not the case but i'm not so
convinced
because it's not necessarily so look i
had it i i talked to
i'm talking to my friend and we're
arguing about
you know like uh um vaccine passports
and requirements stuff like that i'll be
light on the crux of the conversation
because youtube is ban happy but
suffice it to say i said i don't trust
the government
blindly you know i'll consider what they
say and consider the source you always
consider the source
i don't trust big pharma i don't and i
don't understand why the left has come
out in favor of a massive for-profit
venture
to transfer tax funds to major
pharmaceuticals yes
instead of talking about real ways to
help save lives through the health care
system
that being said i think vaccines are
safe and effective i absolutely do
i and and i have one thing i've
absolutely stressed is that we've had
like 360 million doses of the vaccine
theirs is serious one of the like the
very reporting is serious one of the
problems is that
when you censor the conversation you you
freak people out
so this guy is is coming at me arguing
that's by simply telling people
to go talk to their own doctor about
what's right for them and make sure the
doctor
because i genuinely believe it's the
right thing to do because people could
have allergies or whatever
he's like well you're scaring people and
i'm like dude when did you become the
champion of big pharma
what yeah it's about the collective and
not your individual decision and that's
the
point the benefit of the collective over
the individual and the primacy of the
individual is the foundation
you know the fact that every individual
is inherited in the image of god that's
that's america right there exactly my
point so to go back to what we were
talking about before i got into that
that was the idea that there could be
something so
uh innately leftist stop giving taxpayer
funds to
for-profit pharmaceutical companies and
they actively defend it right now
because it's for it's for their their
their collective has formed a narrative
that must be upheld at all costs
that's why we're in a paradigm shift
right now this is the the progressives
are the corporatists now right right
it's like my mom
in the early you know late 60s early 70s
in washington dc
she was a progressive who was fighting
again and i had this conversation with
her the other day and i was just like
yo mom like what's the you know what do
you think about like
you know these modern feminists these
modern and she's like it's
you know i can't say what she said
because she's
um because she's not fairly friendly you
know and that's exactly what we're going
going back to what we were saying
earlier is the critique has become the
mainstream
and so it's no longer revolutionary and
it's become stale and guess what
corporatized
i don't think it's like a corporate
message now wait wait wait wait
you mean you mean the activists yeah
it's mainstream
exactly so i'm saying i thought you're
saying criticizing the woke was made
no no well not yet but i think that you
know
we're in the midst of a shift right now
but all i'm saying is that when my mom
was protesting
in washington dc protesting the vietnam
war
that was very different from you know um
i think
that was a fringe portion of the society
it was the young people who thought
and that now the corporations think just
like those
people who are on the streets that's all
i'm saying thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you